[Music]
elena is the annoying little sister that
says everything that comes to mind with
no consequences
why do you always do that thing what
thing
the pose
it's a fighting pose you're a total
poser
i've never had control over my own life
before and now i do she is discovering
the world in the new light and she meets
scarlett's character natasha for the
first time in 20 years
together they realize that they're both
suffering in very similar ways
natasha
her earliest memories are of the red
room she has this past that she feels
this huge sense of responsibility for
and nothing makes sense
with elena she was also a part of that
world how are they different how are
they similar what makes them tick
she is the next generation of widows she
just thinks some things in a completely
different way
it really is a huge stark contrast to
the way that natasha is used to doing
things and their relationship evolves as
they start to understand where the other
person is coming from
you